steam before this nuclear plant is taken
off the grid activists celebrate what
they call a historic moment
in the side of politicians and it's
great that we have been successful a
victory after 50 years of rallying
against what they call a dangerous
source of energy
the Chernobyl explosion in 1986 in the
then Soviet Union led to a wave of
protests radioactive particles fell in
Germany and elsewhere across Europe
the closure of the three remaining
German plants scheduled to shut down
last year had been postponed because of
the energy crisis sparked by the war in
Ukraine Germany remains deeply divided
about the closure of the nuclear plants
the decision taken by Chancellor Olaf
Schultz after political pressure by his
Coalition part of the greens has been
called irrational during an energy
crisis and a recent survey suggests that
60 of the population want to continue to
use nuclear energy for now 20 professors
at technical universities filed a
petition to reverse the decision it will
increase the CO2 emissions of Germany
and this is the opposite of what Germany
has pledged
second
it will reduce
the reliability of the German Energy
System and third
it will contribute to Rising electricity
prices both for industry and consumers
he says the government will be forced to
use more coal until Germany has found an
affordable way to store renewable energy
closing nuclear plants does not mean the
end of nuclear dangers
Germany is struggling to find a
permanent storage facility for more than
ten thousand tons of Highly radioactive
waste stored at 16 interim locations
much to the concern of the Mayors in
these municipalities
these past 12 months we have become
aware of what it means if there is a war
situation risks we can protect ourselves
against like what we have seen in
Ukraine we don't wish something like
this to happen but we can't exclude it
nuclear waste will now have to stay in
those locations until as late as the
year 2100 before it can be moved to a
permanent location showing that the
nuclear era is far from over stepfast
and Al Jazeera Neko westheim Germany